yeah yeah what are they coloring Jesus
where to get a [ __ ] [ __ ] we where
we're trying to go with it with the look
in the field at the tables and match
everything with the whites and the
blacks Jesus well he's [ __ ] not
impressive God Bobby's in a mess and it
looks dreadful and pretty crap knives
and forks and dreadful tables like
they've been hanging around outside a
pub can't see the end in sight so quite
nervous Guinea two hours two hours is a
long time we didn't come all this way to
lose because we couldn't build tables
downstairs the milestone are much happy
with their tables but they haven't paid
any attention to the rest of their space
the tables look great yeah yeah the
Russian looks [ __ ] there's no thought
process with the targeting of four walls
I'm interested in a stunning restaurant
yeah that's what I would like to see
yeah but have you got any fabrics no
cushions or no all nine pieces of
furniture to liven up no this is it the
idea of a proper restaurant yeah it's
not just the location but it's a shown
off aspect tell me you wear your own
pigs you make your own bread and coming
the dining room it's like I know what
you guys are like when you use your
imagination so I gave me the flexibility
to go and do something out the box
[ __ ] up it's a one night only 2,000
pound to create something exciting and
magical and the wow factor milestone are
going for something simplistic that
played it safe but that may not get you
into the final there's no lack of
ambition in the kitchen however Simon
and James are servants Larry act and
skate scampi with a silver mullet and
braised oxtail accompanied by English
squash and wild mushrooms a short spell
yep so you should be happy that scoop
some time yeah man's taste delicious
pretty nice I'm not always end it i love
it if they pull this food off it will be
amazing what's this one here he's in
there their mother funny he isn't funny
that's delicious that's delicious
pigs are taking shape two tables are
done time is on our hands you got all
the couple on the table for both courses
and without unwrapped it yet do you care
Bobby Kerala you do I I'm worried [ __ ]
cutlery plain-jane dining room and I
know you can do better I'm really sorry
with very little time left before
Prashad open their doors Cal she goes
upstairs to the dining room we have been
some errors you know I thought we can't
constantly focus on them we can't change
those errors right now okay yep
yeah I'm sorry beegley this is it it
shits a bust if it goes bad about the
Sheffield within the best we can but
we're to win it listen to me yeah every
part of what we do is without half with
a 22 c restaurant working our butts off
if we're not good enough we're not good
enough we'll still give it our best shot
we're opening in just under five minutes
from now and this is it everything
they've worked for all day depends on
the service and I've never have and even
that's been so dependent on an amazing
performance in the kitchen because both
freshens have been let down by the front
of house and it's up to the kitchen now
to redeem themselves in a big way and
pull it back